kommt ein entlaufener ochs ins
restaurant was wie der auftakt von einem
witz klingt ist in china tatsächlich
passiert in der chinesischen stadt taser
gut 400 kilometer südlich von shanghai
rast dieses rindvieh plötzlich liebelt
um einen bekannt zwei männer sind im
raum der eine das handy in der hand der
andere trinkt etwas sie unterhalten sich
nichts ahnend auf einmal werden durch
den plastik windschutz des
eingangsbereichs zwei hörner sich
die beiden männer haben kaum zeit zu
reagieren der ochse jagd ins restaurant
und einen mann über den haufen er wird
später mit schweren verletzungen am bein
ins krankenhaus gebracht anschließend
schaut sich das tier noch weiter im
lokal um randaliert noch ein bisschen
und trottet hin und her bevor es wieder
geht angeblich sei das tier von dem
schlachter geflohen behaupten anwohner
ob es eingefangen werden konnte ist
nicht bekannt
[Musik]
[Applaus]